[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم
القاسم وهذه العربيه
بالغه التعقيد والحساسيه ثم لم الشمل في
الجزائر تؤكد على منع التدخلات وحل
الخلافات البينيه وتشدد على مركزيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
ومولد صانع ملوك جديد
الشتاء الذي يراهن عليه بوتا قد يخلف وعده
واوروبا تجرب التقشف ولا تضمن استجابه
الشارع
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
نفسه بجيش مستشارين لقلبه وتر راس على عقب
والهدف زياده ربح المنصه والمستخدمه
[موسيقى]
في كلمته قبل قليل امام قمه لم الشمل في
الجزائر اكد الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد
تبون على ضروره العمل لحل ازمات سوريا
وليبيا واليمن منشدا لاعلاء مبدا الحوار
من اجل حل الخلافات في المنطقه العربيه
تاب تتسبب في تفاقم الازمات
بالمبادئ والاهداف التي تاسست من اجلها
منظمه العربيه
الى النتائج الايجابيه
والمثمره التي سوف
تشاهوريه من اجل تجديد الروح التوافقي
الجامعيه وبلوره الحلول العمليه
القرارات الضروريه لرفع التحديات المفروض
على امتنا في انا في المجالات الامنيه
والسياسيه والاقتصاديه والتنمويه
قيس سعيد في قمه الجزائر من ان العديد من
الدول تواجه حربا دروسا مع من يريدون
اسقاطها
على ضروره توحيد الصف العربي لمواجهه
التحديات واصحاب الفتن في المنطقه
حربا غروسا في مواجهه من يريدون اسقاط
الدول
ولا يمكن
ان نخرج منتصرين غافرين
الا بواحده الصف ولم من الشمس
والقضاء على كل اسباب الفرقه والابتسام
والاتفاق على التكاتف
ينضم الينا من الجزائر محمود الورواري
مفضل العربيه اهلا بك محمود معنا الليله
يعني استمعنا الى كلمات الملوك والرؤساء
العرب في الكلمه الافتتاحيه هل هنالك من
معلومات
مسربه عن ماذا سيتضمن البيان الختامي
مسوده الختامي
طاهر الحقيقه خلينا راويه نضع المشاهد
الكريم فيما حدث بالضبط نحن امام جلسه
افتتاحيه في هذه الجلسه الافتتاحيه هي
جلسه بروتوكليه بامتياز ضمن التقليد الذي
ارسلته الجامعه العربيه منذ ميثاقها عامه
1945 هذه الجلسه بيتم فيها تسليم وتسلم
تسليم من الدوله التي كانت تقود الامه
العربيه اي التي كانت تستضيف القمه
العربيه السابقه الى الدوله التي يعقد
فيها او تعقد فيها القمه العربيه وتتولى
قياده العالم العربي في العام المقبل الذي
حدث ان الرئيس قيس سعيد سلم- القياده الى
الرئيس تبول لكن حدث استثناء راويه دعينا
وضحه هو ان رئيس قيس سعيد لم يقدم كشف
حساب كعاده وتقليد
ابليس الذي يسلم قياده همم الامه لانه لم
يكن هو الرئيس الذي في يحكم تونس في 2019
كان الراحل المرحوم البادجي قائد السبسي
وبالتالي حدث استثناء هذه المره في القمه
العربيه ان الرئيس قيس سعيد لم يقدم كشف
حساب ماذا يعني ما الذي يعنيه كشف حساب
هناك اعلان تونس حواء على 16 بيانا كان من
المفروض ان الدوله التي استضافت القمه ان
تقدم لنا ماذا فعلت خلال هذا هذه الاعوام
التي انقضت الرئيس همم باعتباره
وقائد القمه وهو الذي يتولى قياده الامه
العربيه في السامنه في السنه القادمه قدم
الاستراتيجيه التي هو سيشرف عليها وفيها
نقاط شديده الاهميه راويه اذا كان عندك
وقت ممكن نتحدث فيها لانها تتحدث عن
البيان يعني ما كنا نتوقعه معك وطاهر خلال
الايام الماضيه كنا نتحدث عن برازما يمكن
ان يحويه البيان واضح خلينا نحاول ان
نختصر معك محمود لو سمحت متجليه همم يعني
باطار بابرز ما همم تمكن المجتمعون من
الاتفاق عليه وما هو واضح من انه لن
يستطيع تجاوزه في هذه القمه لو نقتصر ذلك
لندلل على ابرز عناوين ومضامين هذه
المسوده
واضح بالمقارنه ما بين كلمتين طاهر بين
كلمه همم السيد احمد ابو الغيط من العام
لجماعه العربيه وكلمه همم الرئيس تبول
يمكن ان نستشف سويا ما الذي يمكن ان يكون
استراتيجيه عامه في العام القادم اهم ما
جاء من تطابق فالكلمتين كلمه مهمه جدا
فيما يتعلق بالعنوان الفلسطيني وهو عنوان
شديد الاهميه مطلب سيسعد الفلسطينيين
وربما يسعد الرئيس ابو مازن فيما يتعلق
بان هناك اجماع عربي او مطالبه عربيه
لانهم المتحده وجميل ان السيد امين عام
الامم المتحده حاضر ان المجموع العربي
الدول العربيه ستقدم طلب من الامم المتحده
بان تتحول عضويه فلسطين من عضويه مراقب
الى كامله العضويه عضويه كامله هذا الامر
طلب ونقشه وهمم
ظهر في كلمتين كلمه سيد احمد ابو الغيط هو
كلمه الرئيس اذا نحن امام شيء جديد في
القضيه الفلسطينيه هذه المره لم في المرات
القادمه بالهذا المعنى كان موجودا وحاضرنا
القضيه الفلسطينيه لكن تكون هذا المعنى
العنوان الاخر طاهر وهو عنوان شديد
الاهميه هو الشق الاقتصادي وهو الاصرار
على فكره تلافي تداعيات حرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه يعني اعتماد الاستراتيجيه العربيه
التي تحدثت معكم فيها خلال اليومين
الماضيين في ان هذا هو الجديد هذا العام
او التي تمتاز به هذه القمه استراتيجيه
عربيه لتحقيق الامن الغذائي العربي في ضل
دعايات الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه اذا نحن
امام عناوين جديده وامام همم يعني همم
يعني تحديات ربما تكون موجوده على عاتق
الجزائر التي ستتولى قياده الامه خلال
العام القادم شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات
الى الجزائر حيث تعقد القمه العربيه
تحياتنا اليك
للحديث اكثر عن قمه الجزائر معنا من هناك
دكتور توفيق مكعده استاذ العلوم سياسيه
اهلا بك معنا دكتور توفيق مره جديده على
شاشه العربيه
واريد ان ابدا معك بسؤال تفصيلي تحسبا
للوقت فيما يتعلق بالملف الخلافي الابرز
الذي ظل بينكم والمغرب خاصه فيما يتعلق
بموضوع تدخلات الايرانيه التي تم الاتفاق
على همم يعني اذانتها مع التدخلات التركيه
الا ان الجزائر لا يبدو انها فقط على ذلك
عندما تعلق الامر بالبوليساريو ما رايك
اعتقد ان هناك خلاف كبير كذلك في محاوله
قراءه وربط بين التدخلات الايرانيه وكذلك
بين قضيه الصحراء الغربيه
الان على ايران
النقطه التي ربما حدث الاتفاق حولها وليس
ايران فقط وانما تركيا وكل الدول التي
تتدخل في المنطقه العربيه
موجوده في الامم المتحده منذ سنه 1995
وانا العلاقات الجزائريه المغربيه كانت في
احسن حالاتها عندما اتفاق على ان يتم
مسكين القضيه واجعلها
همم
العلاقات البينيه عندما ارادت في المغرب
تجعل من حديث الحراره الغربيه
ازمه في العلاقه البينيه وصلنا الى حاله
القطيع التي نحن عليها الان بتقدري‬»
بالنسبه لهذه القمه ثم يتعلق بكلمه رئيس
الدوله وكذلك للامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه هو محاوله العوده من جديد بالعمل
المشترك عن طريق
جديده من اجل همم تحسين الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه المنطقه العربيه
الايرانيه ما مدى قدره همم قمه الجزائر
على وضع التزامات ربما لدول مثل العراق
ولبنان هي دول ساعات لتدخلات الايرانيه
يعني والا تبقى هذه التعهدات حبرا على ورق
اي قمه سابقا
اعتقد بان العمل العربي وحده القادر على
ان يطرد كل المتدخلين في المنطقه العربيه
في جامعه الدول العربيه على هل حاله
الازمات الاقليميه وكذلك الازمات التي
تعصف بعديد من الدول العربيه
قوى دوليه
ان يوسع من اليته وان يجدد من اليات العمل
في ايجاد حلول
سواء من ايران او تركيا في المنطقه
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور توفيق وقاعده
استاذ العلوم السياسيه من الجزائر تحياتنا
اليك
[موسيقى]
لمره الخامسه في اقل من اربع سنوات يتوجه
الاسرائيليون لصناديق الاقتراع لاختيار
نواب الكنيست انتخابات اليوم قد تشهد عوده
صاحب اطول فتره على راس الحكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو زعيم
ليستلم المنصب في ولايه ثالث
العوده الى السلطه بعدما اطاح به اختلاف
التغيير الذي جمع ثمانيه احزاب وبعد 16
شهرا فشل الائتلاف في تحقيق الاستقرار
السياسي وتسير توقعات الى ان حسبه لكود
سيخرج فائزا من الانتخابات باكبر عدد
مقاعد في الكنيست بشكل منفرد
واظهرت استطلاعات الراي الاخيره التي نشرت
الاسبوع الماضي ان نتنياهو لم يتمكن من
الحصول على 61 مقعدا وهي المطلوبه لضمان
الاغلبيه ما سيفتح الباب لمفاوضات ونقاشات
قد تستمر اسابيع لتشكيل ائتلاف حاكم وربما
هذا سيقود الى الانتخابات جديده حمله ركزت
على مهاجمه اوجه القصور المتصور للحكومه
التي اطاحت بها العام الماضي
وسجلتها ضمها لحزب عربي واليوم بعد
الادلاء بصوته عبرنا ثاني عبر نتنياهو عن
الامل بان يختم حزبه اليوم بابتسامه على
حد قولهم
انه واجب وشرف كبير ان نذهب لتصويت من
الواضح انني اقولها لمؤيدينا ولكن ايضا
بشكل عام لمواطني اسرائيل اخبرتكم انني
كنت قلقا بعد الشيء ولكن اموا ان ننهي
اليوم بابتسامه ولكن الامر متروك للشعب
[موسيقى]
انتخابات اليوم من المتوقع ان تشهد صعود
نجم زعيم حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه ايتامار
بن غفير الذي يعتقد ان حزبه هو من سيوصل
نتنياهو لرئاسه الوزراء تشير التوقعات الى
ان حزب غفير سيصبح ثالث اكبر حزب في
الكنيست ما سيمنحه نفوذا اكبر في اي حكومه
لم يخفي دعمه لنتنياهو يعتبر ان التصويت
لحزبه هو تصويت ايضا كما تعهد بالغاء
محاكمه رئيس الوزراء
اريد ان اعمل بجد
يحصل في صوت واحد على كل من نتنياهو كرئيس
الوزراء وحكومه يمنيه كامله هذا هدفنا
وانا اقول ذلك بوضوح شديد وليست تمكن من
تشكيل حكومه النصف او ربع يمينيه
رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال الذي تولى
المنصب قبل اربعه اشهر يسعى للبقاء في
منصبه لكن الاستطلاعات تشير الى ان حسبه
يشاتيد او هناك مستقبل سيحل في المرتبه
الثانيه بعد اللكود خلال حملته حول لابيد
ترويجه انجازات حكومته في فتره ولايتها
القصيره ومن بينها تحسين العلاقات مع
تركيا صفقه ترسيم الحدود البحريه مع لبنان
اضافه لملف الاقتصاد بعد ادلائه بصوته حتى
لبيد الناخبين على التصويت وقال ان مستقبل
اسرائيل على المحك على حد قوله كان لقيد
مهندس التحالف الاخير برئاسه نفتال بانيت
الذي ضمن المره الاولى حزب العربيا فضلا
عن احزاب من اليسار والوسط واليمين حتى
الان تبدو الصوره غير واضحه تماما حول ما
اذا كان حزب لابيد سيتمكن فعلا مره اخرى
من توحيد الاحزاب المتباينه وتشكيل اختلاف
يكون بديلا عن التحالفينه
هذه الانتخابات خيار بين المستقبل والماضي
اذهبوا وصوت اليوم لاجل مستقبل اطفالنا
وبلدنا صوت جيدا ونتمنى التوفيق للجميع
ونتابع مع مختلف الشخصيات والاحزاب في
الانتخابات الاسرائيليه ولكن معك هذه
المره راويه
خاصه مع تهم الفساد التي يواجهها وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي بنجادس اطلق حملته
الانتخابيه وركز على قضايا الامن القومي
وايضا منعنه ياهو من العوده الى السلطه
ويشير محللون الى ان جانس يعد الشخصيه
الاكثر جاذبيه لاعضاء الكتله المناهضه
لنتانيا له وقد يصبح لاعبا رئيسيا في
مفاوضات في تشكيل الاحتلال في الحاكم بعد
الانتخابات الاستطلاعات الاخيره اشارت الى
ان حزب الوحده الوطنيه بدعمتك جنس سيحل في
المركز الرابع بحصوله على نحو عشره مقاعد
في الكنيسه
ان تجري الانتخابات بهدوء واحترام نحن طرف
الذي يمكنه القيام بذلك يمكننا توحيد دوله
اسرائيل وضمان استقرارها يمكننا ضمان امن
دوله اسرائيل واحترام الجميع
حذر مواطنه اليوم من خطر الوصول بنيامين
نتانيا
بنغفير لعتبه تشكيلي حكومه واكد ان التكتل
الذي يشترك فيه سيعملوا على منع الولايه
ثالثه لبنين نتنياهو في رئاسه الوزراء
[موسيقى]
ان هناك خطرا حقيقيا في ان ينتهي الامر
بتحالف من المتطرفين الذين يشكلون خطرا
على اسرائيل هذا السبب في اننا نبذل قصار
جهدنا لجذب ناخبين الى صناديق الاقتراع
واتمنى ان نفوز
العربيه مع تشتت اللوائح ففي انتخابات عام
2015 حصلت اربعه احزاب عربيه على 15 مقعدا
ثم انخفض العدد في الانتخابات الاخيره
لعشره مقاعد فقط ولا تزال القوائم العربيه
في خطر اذا لم ترتفع نسبه التصويت في
المجتمع العربي ادي ينبغي على كل حال انت
تجاوز نسبه الحزم وهي ثلاثه وربع في المئه
من الاصوات لتكون مؤهله لدخول الكنيسه
بشكل عام تصدر ملفات الامن وارتفاع
الاسعار قائمه مخاوف الناخبين
الاسرائيليين خلال الحملات الانتخابيه
نتابع معكم بعض اراء الشارع الاسرائيلي
امجد حبيبي
للحديث اكثر عن هذا الموضوع معنا من مدينه
الناصره المحلل السياسي نظير مجلى اهلا بك
معنا استاذ نظير ما الذي تقوله اخر
المعطيات مع هذه اللحظات الاخيره قبل
انتهاء هذا اليوم الماراثون الطويل من
الانتخابات الاسرائيليه وهل المشاركه
الكثيفه كانت لصالح من يعني هذه المشاركه
كانت لصالح نتانيا او لخصومه
زياده نسبه التصويت عند اليهود هي بالاساس
وليس عند العرب ولذلك هذه الزياده همم
جاءت همم بعمليا الزياده الملحوظه التي
حصلت في اصوات العرب كما هو معروف مشكلتنا
مع اصوات العرب هي انهم صوتهم بنسبه 45%
فقط وهذه النسبه منخفضه جدا لان النسبه
عند اليهود تزيد عن 70% الان عندما
ناتي بساعه بساعه السابعه يعني قبل همم
ساعه همم ساعه حوالي ساعتين همم بالنسبه ل
66% هذه النسبه غير مسبوقه منذ سنه 99
ولذلك همم من الممكن ان تكون هذه النسبه
اذا لم يرافقها تصاعد في نسبه التصويت
العرب فان هذا يعني ان هنالك خطرا على
جميع العربيه
لماذا برايك يريد نتنياهو العوده الى
الحياه السياسيه الاسرائيليه هل اللي ينفذ
اجوندا وبرنامج سياسي معين انفقت للهروب
من تهم الفساد التي تلاحقه وفي حال وصل
وعاد الى الحياه السياسيه هل هذه الحصانه
تبقى حتى لو وجهت له اذان مباشره
المرافقين له لانه هو الشخصيه التي جاءت
في الوقت المناسب لانقاذ اسرائيل
ولتقدمها في كل مجالات الحياه دوليه
وسياسيا وامنيا واقتصاديا هكذا هو مقتنع
هو المخلص لاسرائيل واا بالطبع همم هنالك
اجنده اخرى انه يناضل من اجل الحياه او
الموت لانها عمليه همم اذا لم يكن رئيسا
للحكومه فهو احتمال كبير ان يكون في السجن
بسبب قضايا الفساد هو مقتنع بانه اذا وصل
الى الحكومه بحكومه يمين متطرف مع بنت فير
ومع الاحزاب الدينيه من الممكن ان يسن
قانون يوقف المحاكمه همم بالضبط وبهذه
الحاله يمكن نفسه همم
الجوهريه بس على ماذا يعتمد الان تحصيله
على واحده 61 مقعد من عدم ذلك هو ناريوهات
اذا لم يحصل هو او خصمه همم خاصه لبيد
يعني بشكل اساسي على 61 مقعد شو خيرت
خيارات هيرتوك الان المعسكران في توازن
معين هو الاستطلاع التغطيه من 59 الى 61
مقعدا صحيح اذا حصل على 61 مقعدا فهو
سيشكل حكومه وهذه الحكومه زي تكون يمنيه
مستقره ولكن متعبه متعبه لان لديه همم
حلفاء من اليمين المتطرف ولديه تحذيرات من
عده دول صديقه لاسرائيل بانه وجود يتمرر
كبير داخل الحكومه هذه المشكله لانه متطرف
لانه عنصر وهذا يسمع في امريكا في اوروبا
في دول الخليج يسمعونها اسرائيل
البديل الاخر ان لا يحصل نتنياه على سته
اكثر من 60 عند اذن همم يحدث ما يحلم به
لبيد
عمليا لان يكون رئيسا للحكومه ان يمنع عن
الثانيه ان يكون رئيس الحكومه ولذلك ستعاد
انتخابات مره سادسه ويكون في هذا الفيديو
رئيس حكومه مره اخرى
عن الاتفاق اتفاق ترسيم الحدود البحريه مع
لبنان قال ساؤ الغيغ هل يمتلك هذه القدره
على الغائه بعد ما صادق عليه الكناسه وام
انها مجرد دعايه انتخابيه خاصه انه هذا
الاتفاق ايضا هو بمباركه امريكيه
الحكومه
ولكن من الناحيه النظريه ويستطيع الغاء
هذا لهذه الاتفاقيه ولكن هذه ستكون سابقه
خطيره في تاريخ اسرائيل ولا اعتقد انه
سيقدم عليه نتنياهو سيحاول ان يغير الصوره
يغير العلاقات مع العالم همم سيحاول ان
يخطط قلق الاسرائيليين من عودته الى الحكم
وحتى في قضيه بن كبير من الممكن ان يطرح
بدائل في قضيه المساواه للعرب هو معني ان
لا يبقى بالصوره التي همم ينظر اليه اا
حول بانه فقط يبحث عن قضيه المحاكمه ويريد
ان يثبت انه القائد الذي يتخذ قرارات
ويتخذ قرارات مسؤوله ولديه كل الامكانيات
فيما بعد ان يدافع عن قراره لماذا تراجعت
عن توقيف الاتفاق مع لبنان لان هذه
المصلحه الاسرائيليه التقديم ذلك ويستطيع
بسهوله ان يغير رايه بعد الانتخابات في
الكثير شكرا جزيلا همم نظير مجال المحل
انا نص رائع شكرا على هذه القراءه تحياتنا
اليك
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا تقارير تنتدح خطط
اوروبا لعبور الشتاء القادم
حول صبر الشارع
[موسيقى]
كل ما تراه
تسمعه
اقراها
قد لا يكون حقيقه
يجب التسليم بها
فمهما بلغت اهميه الخبر
تاكيده او نفيوه
يعتمد فقط على المصدر كواليس وسائل
الاعلام العربيه والعالميه في التفاعل مع
الاخبار على كل المنصات سنحاول ربط خيوط
القصه ونطارد الخبر حتى المصدر من المصدر
الجمعه السابعه والنصف على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في مكالمه هاتفيه مع
الرئيس الاوكراني لتجديد الدعم ندد رئيس
الفرنسيه مانويل ماكرون بقرار روسيا
الانفرادي في ملف تصدير الحبوب
بعدما الحقت روسيا اضرار كبيره بالبنيه
التحتيه للبلاد
الشتاء الذي تحدث عنه مكرو موسى يكون صيفا
بحدين في الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا قد
يستغله الكريمله للضغط على اوروبا وفي
الوقت ذاته قد يكون نقمه على جنوده في
الجاره الغربيه تحاول اذا موسكو استغلال
الشتاء القاسي لكسر دعم القاره العجوز
لاوكرانيا وسط حربه الطاقه والغضب
الاجتماعي المتصاعد في اوروبا تقرير لمجله
نيوزفيك الامريكيه رجح ان يتخذ الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتن هذا النهج بدلا من
تصعيد الامور باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه
فالرجل لم يتخلى على الارجح عن اماله في
تحقيق اهدافه في اوكرانيا من خلال الوسائل
العسكريه التقليديه وهو ما يسعى اليه
بالتوازي مع جهود كسر اراده اوكرانيا في
القتال واراده الغرب بمواصله دعمك لكن
احتمال حدوث ضربه نوويه لا يزال قائما في
حال انهيار جيش الروسي فجاه وتحقيق القوات
الاوكرانيه تقدما كبيرا
وارتفعت اسعار الطاقه بشكل كبير خصوصا في
اوروبا منذ اندلاع الحرب في روسيا اكبر
مصدر للغاز والعقوبات جعلت من الصعب
للغايه على دول الغربيه شراء الغاز الروسي
في حين كانت اوروبا لسنوات عديده تعتمد
بشكل كبير على الغاز والنفط الروسيين
وعليها الان تسريع تنويع استخدام هذه
الطاقه بما في ذلك عن طريق احياء مناجم
الفحم المتوقفه وزياده الاستثمار في
مشاريع الطاقه المتجدده لكن الدعم
للعقوبات الغربيه على روسيا بسبب الحرب قد
يتاكل اذا تفاقمت ازمه تكلفه المعيشه وهو
ما يستغله سيد الكرملين او يحاول اذا
يحاول بوتن استغلال الطقس والشتاء القارس
للضغط على بروكسل لكن
رهان وهو على ذلك قد افشل اذ تشير تقديرات
الطقس المتوقع في اوكرانيا الى ان اوروبا
هدوء شتاء معتدلا تقول نيوز ويك ان سياسيا
روسيا اقترح مؤخرا عبر التلفزيون الحكومي
استهدف امدادات الطاقه في اوكرانيا ما
يتسبب في تجمد المدنيين وتجويعهم وهذا ما
حدث فعلا كشفت روسيا هجمتها على البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه مستهدفه شبكه الكهرباء
ودفعت اجزاء من اوكرانيا الى الظلام وتركت
بعض السكان دون امدادات المياه اقترب
الشتاء او حل بالاحرى لكن التقارير تظهر
ان محاولات استغلال البرد لمصلحه موسكو لا
تسير وفق المخطط ولن تساعد ربما بوتن
بحربه
لشلل الروح المعنويه
الاوكرانييه»
لكن ليس الفضل فقط للشتاء المعتدل المتوقع
بل لما استعدت له دول قاره العجوز للتخلي
عن التقى الروسيه وهو امر نجحت فيها الى
حد بعيد جميع البلدان ليتخذت خطوات
استثنائيه على سبيل المثال هناك اسطول من
الناقلات التي تحمل الغاز الطبيعي المسال
تتزاحم قباله سواحل اسبانيا في انتظار
تفريغ حمولتها الثمينه لشبكات الكهرباء في
اوروبا عندها استغلال الطاقه كسلاح الذي
اتبعه الى تحول مذهل في كيفيه توليد
اوروبا للطاقه وحفظها تحدثت البلدان معا
للشراء ولل بناء امدادات طاقه اضافيه
ولتفعيل خطب طوارئ مثلا ايضا تم تزويد
مواقع التخزين تحت الارض في جميع انحاء
القاره بالكامل بامدادات الغاز الطارئه
كما ستبقى محطات الطاقه النوويه المقرر
اغلاقها في المانيا مفتوحه ومن فرنسا الى
السويد يتم خفضه الحراره الى او منظومات
الحراره الى تسعه 10 درجه مئويه فقط او
الى 66 درجه فهرنهايت حتى ان سلوباكيا
وفنلندا تحث ثاني للناس على قصر فتره
الاستحمام على دقيقتين بينما تعمل اليونان
على تمديد تشغيل جميع محطات توليد الطاقه
التي تعمل بالفحم حتى 20 28 وزياده انتاج
الفحم بنسبه 50% دول عده رفعت القيود
المفروضه على محطات الطاقه التي تعمل
بالفحم بما في ذلك هولندا والمانيا
والنمسا
حتى فرنسا التي كانت في يوم من الايام
اكبر مزود للطاقه النوويه في اوروبا عادت
الى استخدامه طاقه الفحم في بعض المناطق
تكيفت اوروبا مع تخفيضات الروسيه الشديده
اذا في صادرات الغاز توفر موسكو الان اقل
من 10% من الغاز الطبيعي في اوروبا بدلا
من تذكرون الرقم من 45% من امدادات اوروبا
قبل الحرب
[موسيقى]
تنقل صحيفه نيويورك
ان الخطوات التي اتخذتها الدول الاوروبيه
رائعه وستؤدي على الارجح الى تغيير مشهد
الطاقه يضيف ان اوروبا ستنجح في الانفصال
تماما عن روسيا وهو امر كما ينظر اليه
سابقا على انه مستحيل لكن ومع ذلك فان
تكلفه الوحده هذه مرتفعه ويمكن تفويض او
تفويض امن الطاقه في اوروبا في الاشهر
المقبله وقد يقرر بعض الاوروبيين انهم
ليسوا مستعدين بعد لتقديم تضحيات شخصيه
بعد كل شيء فعلوه لتقديم تضحيات شخصيه
لاوكرانيا والاوكرانيين مع ارتفاع فواتير
الطاقه المنزليه الدليل الاحتجاجات التي
اندلعت في الشوارع ضد ارتفاع تكاليف
المعيشه في باريس
عاصم اخرى
[موسيقى]
معنى من باريس دكتور حسن عبيد تفضلي
العلوم الماليه اهلا بك دكتور
قد لا ينجح معه لانه التقارير تتحدث بانه
ال هذا الشتاء قد يكون متوسطا الدول
الاوروبيه تقول بانه خزنات مولات هل
المشكله بملء الخزانات ام باسعارها لانه
كما نعلم هذه الخزانات ملات باسعار مرتفعه
وبالتالي عندما ستذهب الى المستهلك ستكون
ايضا باسعار مرتفعه هل همم من ضامن لي رده
فعل الناس
للشعوب الاوروبيه الغاضبه اصلا على سياسات
حكوماتها
يعني هي الرابطه على سياسات مساء الخير
بالحقيقه هي غاضبه على سياسات حكوماتها
لما وصلت اليها الامور لان نسبه التضخم في
اوروبا وصلت الى تحطت عتبه العشره بالمئه
بينما كانت في سبتمبر يعني ظهرت المؤشرات
منذ يومين مؤشرات شهر اكتوبر فكانت 9.8 في
عام في سبتمبر اما اليوم فنحن اشرف واحد
بالمئه
زاد ايضا ال- ال- الصندوق او البنك
المركزي الاوروبي ازاده من معدلات الفائده
همم
50 نقطه
لاحتواء معدلات التضخم وبالتالي همم
الشوارع الاوروبيه همم
في بعض العواصم اوروبيه في باريس وغيرها
بالناس احتجاجها على هذه الامور اما همم
فهناك ربما يمكن او قول ان هناك عنايه
الهيه همم يعني همم اوروبيه همم لم تزعل
حتى اليوم هي بالطق الجيد لم نزل ننعم به
هنا في اوروبا لانه كان من المتوقع ان
يكون هناك طقس بارد واستخدام الغاز بطريقه
مذهله وطريقه رهيبه ما يؤدي الى بالفعل
الطلب على الغاز هذا امر يعني مع هذه
النظره التفاعليه التي عرضنا لها قبل قليل
همم يعني اشركت بهذا الخبر العازل ايضا عن
اعلان ماسك عن رسم شهري مقداره ثمانيه
دولارات للحساب الموثق في تويتر ما بعرف
اذا حساباتك همم موثقه ولا لا ولا راح
تدفع ثمانيه دولار ولا لا على عموم هناك
الكثير من الناس الذين كانوا يعني يهرولون
من اجل توثيق حساباتهم الان لا اعتقد انهم
سيفعلون ذلك ولكن بالعوده الى موضوعنا
دكتور هل يعتقد ان تفاؤل في محله ام انه
هذا التسويق دعائي لا اكثر او نظره
تفاؤليه ليست في محلها لانه يعني من غير
معقول ان تكون الامور قد انقلبت راسا على
عقد بعد كل ما كنا نتحدث عنه في هذا
الاطار في الاشهر الماضيه
لا بدنا نكون بدنا نكون واقعيين يعني
بالحقيقه كنت عم بحكيك على المستوى عن
معدل تضخم وايضا كريستين لاجرد رئيسه
المصرف ال ال يعني المصيف
المركزي الاوروبي تقول ان النذاهبون الى
ازمه كبيره ازمه تضخم وازمه ركود وربما
ازمه كساد يعني اذا ما استمرت الامور على
مائيه فلنكن واقعي نعم اوروبا اليوم عندها
عده تمور بما اختصاص الغاز اولا الحصول
على الخاص ثانيا سعر الغاز وثا استهلاك
الغاز يعني الطاقه بشكل عام وليس فقط
الاستغلال ربما ربما نجحت بعض الشيء همم
بعمليه همم ترشيد الانفاق من الطاقه وايضا
همم يعني استخدام الطاقه البديله واستخدام
العوده الى استخدام الفحم ولكن العوده
للاستخدام الفحم ليس بالامر الجيد ايضا
لانه يؤدي الى تلبيس همم التلوث في البيئه
وفي فرنسا نعرف ان هناك ايضا استخدام
الطاقه النوويه والدهونه ايضا اسئله كبيره
ودونه همم
امكانيات تقنيه لابد من النظر اليه
فالموضوع ليس بهذه السهوله لا تحدثهم لم
نخرج همم بعد من الازمه ولكن لنضع الامور
لنصعبها سليم ان شاء الله في لقاء اخرى
ايضا نتابع في وضعها في نطاقها او نصابها
السليم معك شكرا دكتور حسن عبيد استاذ همم
الاستاذ الجامعي والباحث في العلوم
الماليه والاقتصاديه من باريس تحياتنا
اليك
[موسيقى]
وعلى وقع الخبر العاجل عن ثمانيه دولارات
رسوم شهريه لتوثيق الحساب او للحساب
الموثق في تويتر بالاحرى متابعه العربيه
360 اغنى رجل في العالم الى الماسك لم
يشتري موقع تويتر ليحرره من القيود على
الراي فقط
رجل الاعمال اكثر من ناجح لديه بالفعل
الكثير من الخطط لجميع الارباح من الطائر
الازرق مستعينا بجيش من المستشارين من
شركه الرائده الملك الجديد للمنصه الشهيره
يستعد بسرعه للعمل مع نحو 50 مهندسا اتى
بهم من شركه تسلا التي يملكها ايضا
يستعدون للعمل على مجموعه من المبادرات
لمحاوله تعزيز تجربه المغردين ورفع ارباح
اغنى اغنياء العالم سيضيف طرقا لمنشئي
المحتوى من اجل ربح المال عبر تويتر مثل
ما يفعل العديد من صانع المحتوى كما
تعرفون على تيك توك ويوتيوب اضافه الى
غيرهما وفقا ما نقلت ووسط جورنال
خطه مصر تشمل تغيير النظام الاساسي لتويتر
من خلال توسيع نطاق التحقق من المستخدمين
وتحسين عروض الاشتراك لتقليل الاعتماد على
المعلمين ولتحقيق الاهداف احط ماسك نفسه
بمجموعه من المستشارين الموثوق بهم
والموهوبين التقنيين من بين هؤلاء جيسون
ومنحوهما مسمى مهندس برامج الموظفين بينما
لقب ماسك نفسه في دليل الشركه للرئيس
التنفيذي لتويتر رغم ان هذا المنصب لم يتم
الاعلان عنه وفق ما ذكرت صحيفه واشنطن
الامريكي
لكن ذلك لديه العديد من الخطط التي
تتناقضوا مع اهدافه المشرقه واشنطن بوست
نقلت عن الدائره المقربه من مصر عزومه
تسريحات ما يقرب من 75 في المئه من موظفي
تويتر رقم مهول تستهدف الجوله الاولى من
التسريح بقياده محامي
25 بالمئه من القوه العامله البالغ عددها
7000 موظف عمليات التسريح ستلحق الضرر
بجميع الادارات تقريبا ومن المتوقع ان
تؤثر بشكل خاص على المبيعات على المنتجات
الهندسه الثقه السلامه في الايام القليله
المقبله وفق مصدر مطلع تحدث للصحيفه
الامريكيه لكن الملياردير ماسك غرد نافيا
تقريرا واشنطن بوست عن نيته تسريحه هذا
العدد الهائل من الموظفين معتبرا ان الامر
ليس صحيحا
السابق هذا العام الشركاء محتملين في
الصفقه انه يخطط لخفض ما يقرب من 75% من
اجمالي القوى العامله في تويتر امر ان تم
سيطرك للشركه حوالي 2,000 موظف فيما قال
شخص اخر مطلع على الصفقه ان العديد
الاجمالي او العدد لعمليات التسريح من
المرجح ان يقترب من 50% تقول مصادر واشنطن
بوست ان عمليات التسريح قد تبدا هذه
الايام ومن المقرر ان يتلقى موظفو تويتر
تعويضات اضافيه تتعلق
بمنح الاسهم الاحد المقبل والاحد الماضي
غرد ماسك بان الابلاغ عن التسريح وشكل
العمال على تويتر الاسبوع المقبل كاذب لكن
قبل شراء ماسك لتويتر ولا اكثر من عقد من
الزمان قام المليار دار الامريكي بتحريك
الشبكه الاجتماعيه
باستفزازاته ونكاته نكاته الغريبه اليوم
سيطره على الشبكه فعليه ورحب به الرئيس
صعبه دونالد ترامب قائلا انا سعيد جدا لان
تويتر اصبح الان في ايدن امينه الرجل الذي
يتابع حسابه 100 و12 مليون مشترك غرد في
السابع والعشرين من الشهر الماضي متغنيا
بان الطائر اصبح حرا بذلك كثيرون فعلا
لكنه هوجم بشده من اخرين مجله ويرد
المرجعيه للتكنولوجيا في امريكا كتبت في
الثامن والعشرين من الشهر المنصرم ان
الفوضى ستسود تويتر تحت قياده الماسك
المجله ارجع ذلك الى مواقف ماسك المتناقضه
بشان الاستراتيجيه التي يجب اتباعها في
الشركه وبشان قواعد الاعتدال التي يريد
تطبيقها على المنصه وعمليات التصريح لكن
الفوضى ليست في الواقع وضعا جديدا على
الشبكه الاجتماعيه التي يتخلل تاريخها
القصير ازمات الحوكما والتغيرات
الاستراتيجيه المفاجاه بالفعل غير كانت
تويتر الرئيس التنفيذي لها اربع مرات منذ
انطلاقها حتى اليوم لتكون اكثر شركه في
السليكون فالي تفعل ذا
وهذه الصوره ايضا
على الرسوم الجديد على اصحاب الحسابات
الموثقه اذا ماذا تقول هذه الصوره لو همم
الدولارات امريكيه على كل حساب موثق في
تويتر همم يعني واحده من اهم القرارات
التي يتخذها منذ تولي منصبه في الايام
الماضيه
طبعا لا نعلم ان كانت يعني تطبيقات اخرى
غير تابعه ل همم الالماس مثل الانستغرام
وفيسبوك ربما تحدثات سننتظر صحيحه
واياكم في العربيه 360 بعد الفاصل ايضا في
لبنان ان احتجت مساعده ستجد من يلبيك
مكانان فقط لا تجرب فيهما لن يرد عليك احد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت صحيفه جورنا
الامريكيه ان السعوديه تبدلت معلومات
استخباراتيه مع الولايات المتحده حول
هجمات ايرانيه محتمله
في الدوله
المجاوره مستوى التاهب لقواتها العسكريه
حسب ما قالت وولت سيجنال الصحيفه نقلت عن
مسؤولين سعوديين قولهم ان ايران تستعدوا
لشن هجمات في محاوله لصرف الانتباه عن
الاحتجاجات التي تعصف بها منذ سبتمبر
فيما قال مجلس الامن القومي بالبيت الابيض
انه على علم بالتحذيرات السعوديه واعلن ان
الولايات المتحده مستعده للرد اذا نفذت
ايران هجوما
في ملف في انتخابات التجديد النصفي
الامريكيه اعتبرت وزاره العدل مراقبه
نشطاء يمنيين لصناديق الاقتراع خلال
الانتخابات النصفيه امرا يروع الناخبين
وقررت الوزاره المشاركه في دعوى قضائيه
اقمتها رابطه ان خبات في اريزونا ضد جماعه
يمنيه تؤكد ان انتخابات عام 2020 كانت
مزوره وانه سيتم ارسال حراس مسلحين
لمراقبه صناديق الاقتراعه
باصدار امر من المحكمه لحظر التجمعات
المسلحه بالقرب من صناديق الاقتراع
وتدخل سباق الانتخابات النصفيه في اريزونا
على منصب الحاكم الجمهوريه كاريليك
المدعومه من ترامب والتي تؤكد ان انتخابات
عام 2020 كانت مزوره
وتعهد اليك في حال فوزها بانها لم تعتمد
نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2014 اذا
اعتقدت انها تم تزويرها كان انتخابات عام
2020 على حد وصفها
[موسيقى]
في صحراء
واحده من اكثر معارك انتخابات التجديد
النصفي التنافسيه على منصب الحاكم بين
الجمهوريه كيرليك والديمقراطيه
وبينهما الكثير من الاستقطاب
كاريك هي نجمه الحزب الجمهوري الجديده
اختارها ترامب بنفسه لخوض السباق وتتبنى
خطابه بتزوير انتخابات عام 2020
انا السيده زينب
[تصفيق]
الرئيس على بطاقه ترامب اذا قرر خوض سباق
عام 2014
[موسيقى]
السقف نظام
النائبه الجمهوريه التي تشارك في تحقيقات
اقتحام الكبتل وتسببت ترامب في خسارتها
الانتخابات التمهيديه لهذا السبب تدعمه
ايضا يدعمها النائب الجمهوري ادم كان زنجر
الذي يشارك في تحقيقات الكابتل ووفر على
نفسه اهانه خساره الانتخابات التمهيديه
باعلانه عدم الترشح مجددا
استطلاعات الراي لم تحسمه هويه الفائز في
سباق حاكم اريزونا افضليه بسيطه للغايه
للمرشحات الجمهوريه تدعمها انتقادات
للمرشحات الديمقراطيه التي ترفض اجراء
مناظره ويؤكد معارضها انها خائفه من احراج
علني
[موسيقى]
اذا الرئيس البرازيلي
عمليا بعد خسارته الانتخابات يقول سالتزم
بالدستور كان الكل يتوقع عن تطول هذه
المعركه راويه واا بانه سنبدا باجراءات
نقل السلطه للرئيس الجديد قريبا هكذا يقول
مساعدون بول سونار نتحاول الان الى الموجز
الرياضي
[موسيقى]
اخبار الرياضه
اليوم قرعه مسابقه كاس خادم الحرمين في
قريه الدرعيه الرياضيه بمشاركه انديه دوري
روسيا السعودي للمحترفين اعتبارا من دوري
السته عشر لنظام خروج المغلوب من مباراه
واحده حتى الوصول الى المباراه النهائيه
ويستهل الفيحاء حامل اللقب بصيرته بملاقات
الخليج بما تبرز مباراه الاتحاد وضيفه
الشباب قمه مباريات الدوري النهائي اليكم
جدول المباريات
العيال بتكون ان شاء الله 20 الى 22
ديسمبر دور 16 وايضا نصف النهائي بربع
النهائي بيكون في منتصف مارس
نصف النهائي بيكون فيها اواخر ابريل ان
شاء الله ونسيتم الاعلان عنها مباشره ان
شاء الله واتفاق كل الانديه صحيح تم
المناقشه على الرزنامه بشكل كامل وانت
تعرف روزنامه السنه هذه مع التوقف اللي
صار لكاس العالم هتكون شوي مضغوطه في جميع
الفرق المشاركه
ستقوم واحد دور المزيدات الشهيره بعرض كره
القدم التي سجل بها ديكو مارادونا هدفه
الشهير خلال مباراه منتخب الارجنتين ضد
نظيره الانجليزي في ربع نهائي كاس العالم
عام 86 في المكسيك والذي سجله بيده كنا
حكم المباراه التونسي علي بن ناصر اخذ
الكره بعد اللقاء واحتفظ بها منذ ذلك
الحين في منزله ناصر سوف يعرض الكره
الشهيره للبيع في مازال علني هذا الشهر مع
تخصص جزء من العائدات للاعمال الخيريه ومن
المتوقع ان تباع الكره بمبلغ يتراوح بين
مليونين الى ثلاثه ملايين جنيه
اكد الاسباني فليكس سانشيز مدرب منتخب قطر
ان البرازيل هي المرشح الدائم للفوز بكاس
العالم لافتا الى ان منتخب الارجنتين يعيش
في فتره رائعه بالاضافه الى منتخب بلاده
اسبانيا وهي مرشحه دائما حسب تصريح نشرته
صحيفه ماركه الاسبانيه المدرب الذي قاد
قطر لتحقيقه اول لقب لها في كاس اسيا 2019
اكد انه من الصعب جدا على منتخب قطر
زمام المبادره ضد منتخبات هذه البطوله لان
هذا هو الواقع مشددا على ان محاوله لاعبي
دوري البطوله ستكون اتحاد
رجعها ببيب جوارديون لا مدرب ومانشستر
سيتي تعافي اكيل ووكر وقت فيلبس ثنائي
منتخب انجلترا من الاصابه قبل انطلاق كاس
العالم وخضع وكر لجراحه في ال الفخذ مطلع
اكتوبر بيننا غاب فيليبس بسبب مشكلتهم
ويسابق الثنائي الزمالك
اكد انتر ميلان ان المهاجم البلجيكي
روميلو لوكاكو يعاني من اجهاد في عضلات
الفخذ اليسرى وسيخضع للمراقبه هذا الاسبوع
للتاكد من مدى الاصابه ويعتقد روبيرتو
مارتينيز مدربه بلجيكا ان غياب روميلو
لوكاكو الذي لا بديل له عن كاس العالم
سيجبر فريقه على تغيير طريقه لاعبه لكن
المهاجمه لم يتاكد غيابه حتى الان وفقا
لما اعلنه طبيب الفريق
استبعد هاجيب مورياسه مدرب اليابان
الثنائي
مهاجم سيلتك ويويا وساكو مهاجم كوبي بي سي
من قائمته المكونه من سته وعشرين لاعبا
لكاس العالم ورياسه قال انه اختار لاعبين
بطموحنا له بشكل اهم من الخبره في
النهائيات ولم يتجاوز منتخب اليابان من
قبل دوره سته عشر في كاس العالم لكنه ريال
سوسه يستهدف دور الثمانيه رغم الوقوع في
المجموعه الخامسه التي تضم المانيا
وكوستاريكا
يحتاج ميلان الايطالي الى التعادل لحجز
البطاقتين الاخيرتين المؤهلتين الى ثمن
نهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا ويستقبل الفريق
الايطالي
ضمن المنافسات في المجموعه الخامسه بينما
يحل العازل ضيفا على الشختار الاوكراني في
المجموعه السادسه ويحتل ميلان المركز
الثاني في المجموعه التي حجزت تشيلسي
بطاقته الاولى وبفارق النقطه امام سازبر
والامهاته بالنسبه
للمجموعته التي ضمن
ريال مدريد الاسباني حامل لقب بطاقتها
الاولى
بفارق ثلاث نقاط امام
كانت هذه ابرز اخبار رياضه عوده الان الى
راويه وطاهر الاستقلال العربيه 360
[موسيقى]
شكرا لمحمد في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360
راويه
الركود في منطقه
اليورود رئيسه البنك المركزي الاوروبيه
التي تعهدت ايضا بتحجيم مغول التضخم
وباعادته الى نسبه اثنين بالمئه البنوك
الكبرى راويه ماذا فعلت
تمت امرها اذا ركو تحت السيطره خير من
تضخم خارج عن السيطره لكن كل هذا قبل
الشتاء التي تحذر التقارير من انه لن يجمد
الخطط فقط بل ربما سيجمد اصحابها ايضا
3060 يناديه الشعب فخامه رئيس الجمهوريه
نحتاج لقرارات عازله لانقاذ لبنان من
انهيار صنفه البنك الدولي على انه من بين
الاسوء عالميا منذ عقود
شو لاجراءات تنتشل 80% من اللبنانيين او
بعضا منهم على الاقل من تحت خط الفقر لكن
لست اجابات ربما يجرب اللبنانيون مع كرسي
اخر دوله رئيس الوزراء نحتاج الى حل مشكله
الغذاء الغلاء الفاحش ربما خطوه ما ترفع
الحج عن اموال المذيعين في المصارف او
خطوه اخرى تعيد لليره بعضا من قيمتها
لنركز على الاهم موافقات على بدء تنقيب
واستخراج الغاز بموجب على اتفاق الذي هلل
له الجميع لكن ايضا الاستجابه هذا هو
لبنان في يومه الاول مع الفراغ فراس افرغت
ليس فقط من الاشخاص وانما ايضا
من المطبخ